how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to the channel today we're
gonna talk about a character that
everybody loves that everybody is dying
to see and the MCU and talk about the
only actor that we can see playing him
and of course we are talking about
Wolverine and Hugh Jackman Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine could return and
could be in the MCU now before we dive
into this topic let me make something
very very clear this is not about Hugh
Jackman returning to the MCU to play
Wolverine for the next 10 to 15 years
that is not going to happen what this
video is about is the very real
possibility of him returning as the
character in the MCU for a single movie
or for a cameo a return nonetheless that
everybody would be super excited about
but Hugh Jackman is not going to return
and play the character for another 10
years do another five six movies that's
just not going to happen but we have
some new reports today and I'll go over
some recent reports in the past that say
we could see Hugh Jackman's Wolverine in
the MCU I'll talk about what Hugh
Jackman has said himself about returning
talk about how he himself said that if
he could be next to the Avengers he
probably would return the very real
possibility of him coming to the MCU to
play his character Wolverine one more
time for films such as Wolverine versus
the Hulk Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness and of course
Deadpool 3 I will break down all of that
in this video but a quick reminder that
I'm still doing my Xbox one and ps4
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be subscribed to my channel like this
video and comment below with your
thoughts I'm picking the winner at five
hundred and fifty thousand subscribers
so we'll start off with the most recent
report and then dive into what would it
take to bring Hugh Jackman back and how
it's a very real possibility the first
report is from a Twitter account called
smart Tom who has leaked some things in
the past and in his tweet he said I
heard that Sir Patrick Stewart's
meeting with Kevin Feige was for a
potential cameo and Doctor Strange in
the multiverse of madness
remember Professor X's dementia in Logan
Doctor Strange may pop out of a portal
during a scene in the water tank but
vanish just as Hugh Jackman's Wolverine
comes through the door and makes a crack
about him talking to himself again quick
gag that will bring down the house and
not interfere with any Canon just a wink
and a smile this also leaves that back
to where
for Deadpool to jump in the MCU this
would be absolutely incredible a quick
little cameo from Patrick Stewart and
Hugh Jackman's Wolverine that would
actually be in the MCU because Doctor
Strange in the multiverse of madness of
course is in the MCU but him opening a
portal and then closing the portal would
have no significant effect on the MCU
and like the report said it wouldn't
affect the Canon this would almost be a
perfect way for Hugh Jackman to return
and Sir Patrick Stewart as well and it's
a very likely way that he could return
but probably not the most likely and if
you missed it a few days ago Patrick
Stewart in an interview addressed
whether or not he would return to the
MCU to play the character Professor
Xavier and I shouldn't say return to the
MCU I should say return to play the
character and then be a part of the MCU
but he revealed that he spoke with Kevin
Feige and that Kevin Feige wanted him
back in the interview he said I met with
Kevin Feige a couple of months ago and
we had long long conversations and there
have been moves and suggestions which
include Charles Xavier but here's where
it gets tricky because he goes on to say
not only something that affects the
return of his character for Professor
Xavier but Hugh Jackman's return as
Wolverine as well he says here's the
problem if we had not made Logan than
yes I would probably be ready to get
into that wheelchair at one more time
and be Charles Xavier but Logan changed
all that and he goes on to say that the
reason Loken changed all of that is
because two characters died in that
movie obviously his character Professor
Xavier and Hugh Jackman's Wolverine and
they both said goodbye to their
characters and that leads to actually
something pretty positive with the MCU
you see there's really only two reasons
why Hugh Jackman wouldn't return to play
his character Wolverine in the MC one
more time and luckily for us those two
reasons are pretty easy for Marvel
Studios to get over and Hugh Jackman
himself has even stated after the
release of Logan that there are ways
that he could and would come back and
I'll talk about those in just a second
but the two reasons that he wouldn't
come back are one his character is dead
he said goodbye to Wolverine he's at
peace with it and he wouldn't want
Wolverine being brought back to life and
the other reason is that he's simply too
old to take on a character that he would
have to commit to playing for another 10
to 15 years both completely
understandable reasons to not return to
do a cameo for Wolverine one last
but like I said luckily for us they're
pretty easy to get around and one really
easy way to get around both of these is
the continuity of the new MCU that we
live in the multiverse is real we can
now have things happen in the MCU that
we could only dream about happening and
one of the great things about this is is
that we could have Wolverine returned
without really reviving the character
and without Hugh Jackman having to
commit to play the character for many
many years he could simply appear in a
single film in a different reality the
supposedly from smart Tom is a perfect
example Doctor Strange opens a portal to
a different reality and there we see
Hugh Jackman's Wolverine and Patrick
Stewart's Professor Xavier that puts
them in the movie but has absolutely no
effect whatsoever doesn't revive the
characters because it doesn't affect
Logan at all and it's a brief cameo and
probably doesn't require Hugh Jackman to
get into that super rip shape that he
always has been in to play Wolverine
this is actually exactly what he did in
x-men first class when Professor X and
Magneto of the pass went and saw him in
a bar he told them to basically screw
off it was literally a five second cameo
in a movie now we know some people right
now we're thinking but Hugh Jackman said
he was done with the character after
Logan yes that's true but let's remember
what else he said after Logan following
the release of Logan he said that there
is one way that he would return to play
the character of Wolverine he said the
Avengers would prove too much to turn
down because I always loved the idea of
Wolverine with that dynamic with the
Hulk obviously with Ironman but there
are a lot of smarter people with MBAs
who can't figure that out you never know
at the moment honestly if I really did
have them there I probably wouldn't have
said this is the last so let me explain
a few things about this because this was
in 2017 when Hugh Jackman says but there
are a lot of smarter people with MBAs
who can't figure that out he's talking
about the Disney Foxx deal at this point
in time the rights to Wolverine were
with Fox they weren't with Marvel
Studios and Disney yet therefore
Wolverine could not legally and
technically be a part of the MCU and be
with the other Avengers well of course
as we know Marvel Studios now does have
the rights to all of the x-men including
Wolverine so now it's a very real
possibility for Wolverine to be with the
Avengers granted the
Avengers and not Ironman because of
course he's gone but the Hulk is
definitely still out there which I'll
talk about in a bit but then at the end
when he said at the moment honestly if I
really did have them there I probably
wouldn't have said this is the last and
what he's talking about here when he
says if I really did have them there
he's talking about the Avengers if I
really did have the Avengers there to be
with I wouldn't have said that this is
my last time playing Wolverine in Logan
so Hugh Jackman said that the only way
that he would return is if he could be
with the Avengers and now that is
possible and not only is it possible but
it's pretty much confirmed that Kevin
Feige has met with Hugh Jackman Patrick
Stewart has confirmed that he met with
Kevin Feige to reprise his role for
Professor Xavier there's no doubt that
he met with Hugh Jackman as well because
Wolverine is a fan favorite and if
there's any character that everybody
wants to see come over from the Fox
family its Wolverine which leads us to
our reports of how Hugh Jackman could
return in which film he could return in
he could actually return in many ways
that would be perfect for him but let's
talk about the reports of course there's
the first one that I already mentioned
of him returning and Doctor Strange and
the multiverse of madness for a quick
cameo but we have another report by
Mikey Sutton that came out not too long
ago that said that he could return in a
Hulk vs. Wolverine movie now this is
something that both Hugh Jackman and
Mark Ruffalo have expressed interest in
in the past and recently Mark Ruffalo
said in an interview that he has an
upcoming meeting with Kevin Feige to
talk about the future possibilities of
the Hulk and in that same interview he
also said that he would love to see a
Hulk vs. Wolverine movie so we can
presume that that's one of the movies
that he would pitch and again Hugh
Jackman said in an interview if he could
come back and interact with the Hulk
inside of the MCU he would and the cool
thing is that this could be a one-off
movie yes Marvel does have the Marvel
Cinematic Universe but not everything
has to connect or if it does not
everything has to be in the same reality
now they can do one-off movies and they
can do movies that don't really affect
the Canon of the main MCU timeline which
is perfect for Hugh Jackman he could
return and fulfill his fantasy of
appearing next to the Hulk but he
wouldn't have to commit to another 10 to
15 years of the character and now it's
been reported that Marvel does have the
full rights to the Hulk again so they
could do
a Hulk vs. Wolverine film and put the
Hulk's name in the title which would of
course attract so many different viewers
so many people would see that movie so
he could return for that but the one
that he is most likely to return in of
course is Deadpool three Hugh Jackman
and Ryan Reynolds are best friends they
are super close and Ryan Reynolds has
been begging Hugh Jackman to return one
less time as Wolverine and one of his
Deadpool films
well now Deadpool is in the MCU and Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine could be in the MCU
as well and the best part about him
being in Deadpool 3 is that it would be
hilarious and they would crack jokes at
one another's expense and Deadpool
doesn't necessarily have to really
affect the MCU it's been speculated that
yes of course
Deadpool 3 is going to be in the MCU
however the events of Deadpool 3 will
most likely not affect the MCU this will
almost be like an agent of shield type
of deal whatever happens in the main MCU
timeline involving the Avengers will
affect what happens in the Deadpool
movie however what happens in the
Deadpool movies most likely will not
affect a main MCU timeline and what
happens with the Avengers films and this
is most likely due to the fact that they
want to keep Deadpool rated R Ryan
Reynolds and the Deadpool crew have
figured out a way to make the film work
everybody loves the two Deadpool films
and they don't want to mess it up but
they don't want a movie that's rated R
to be in the MCU as well but again this
gets rid of the two reasons that Hugh
Jackman wouldn't return to play his
character if he returned to Deadpool 3
it would be only for one film and of
course Deadpool has the ability to break
the fourth wall so he could say
something like yeah technically his
character is dead but I begged him so
much that he returned for just one film
again this is most likely to happen
because Ryan Reynolds is best friends
with Hugh Jackman and he's been begging
him for years to return to the character
he was already said that he would return
if he could be a part of the Avengers
team in the MCU
but being with Deadpool his best friend
and the MCU was probably going to do the
trick as well Patrick Stewart has met
with Kevin Feige about reprising the
role of Professor Xavier so it's most
likely that Hugh Jackman has met with
Kevin Feige as well and let's be honest
actors say no to return into roles but
Marvel Studios has the ability to throw
a ton of cash at Hugh Jackman so these
reports of Hugh Jackman possibly
returning for these three movies are
absolutely and entirely possible Hugh
Jackman has said himself that he's
been upto returning under certain
circumstances and it seems like those
circumstances may be falling into place
of course nothing is confirmed right now
but we can always hope let me know what
movie you would like to see Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine return in and the
MCU don't forget to like the video and
subscribe and notifications turned on so
you can stay up to date on everything
relating to the MCU as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof woof